what is domain adaptation
when fine-tuning a pre-trained model on
a new data set the fine-tuned model we
obtain will make predictions that are
attuned to this new data set
when the two models are trained with the
same task
we can then compare their predictions on
the same input
the predictions of the two models will
be different in a way that reflects the
differences between the two data sets
a phenomenon we call domain adaptation
let's look at an example with mass
language modeling
by comparing the outputs of the
pre-trained distilbert model with the
version fine-tuned in chapter 7 of the
course link below
the retrain model makes generic
predictions whereas the fine-tuned model
has its first two predictions linked to
cinema
since it was fine-tuned on a movie
reviews data set it's perfectly normal
to see it adapted in suggestions like
this
notice how it keeps the same prediction
as a pretrained model afterward
even if the function model adapts to the
new data set it's not forgetting what it
was pre-trained on
this is another example on a translation
task
on top with the pre-trained french
english model and at the bottom the
version we find unique chapter 7.
the top model is retrained on lots of
texts and leaves technical english terms
like plugging in an email and changes
the translation
both are perfectly understood by french
people
the data set picked for the fine tuning
is a set of technical texts where
special attention was picked on
translating everything in french
as a result the fine-tuned model picked
that a bit and translated both plugin
and email